well the tension between russia and
ukraine has on one valley artist just
heartbroken her brother is doing what he
can to survive the attacks in ukraine
and now efforts to assist are underway
christian casares he's joining us live
in our studio tonight with more on their
story and how our community christian
can help that's right well elena warey
is a ukrainian russian artist right here
in las vegas the war has deeply impacted
her family and her friends while the
devastation continues she is hoping to
bring some relief through the arts to
those in need
my heart breaks for ukrainians who are
dying elena wary has been filled with
many emotions since war broke out
between russia where she was born and
ukraine where she was raised even though
she is thousands of miles away from
danger her family is constantly on her
mind my brother is in ukraine and he is
in
mecca life which is a big city in the
south of ukraine
and
it was bombed
the first day the first morning when the
war started
mostly i work on paper to ease her
attention where he has focused on her
passion painting a skill that she says
has allowed her to think back of happier
times while reflecting on her pain i
painted this woman and i thought well
that reminds me something about
syrian people suffering where he says
her brother in ukraine has health
problems and is still helping his
community by transporting residents away
from war zones he tells them
how many seats he has left for
tomorrow's bus and
you know how he can help them some
people asking about
holding kids on the laps
here at home weary is also organizing a
charity event to send help to those
fighting to survive she's also dealing
with loved ones in russia who don't see
eye to eye on the war unlike her brother
i think he's a hero
really
yes
he he is risking his life
well where he says all she can do right
now is pray and also help now she's
working with her husband who is a
musician here in town to host a
fundraiser which is open to the public
now we have all that information all
those details on our website right now
eightnewsnow.com christian casa is live
local now